this happens every other week over the
past four years and I'm not used to it
so you have a pitch meeting for me yes
sir I do it's for a terrible terrible
movie by Sony Pictures animation yeah
yeah oh you know Sony oh my god we're
gonna watch Brian George mysterion's
pitch meeting for the emoji movie this
came out a long time ago eight years ago
20 17 years I've never seen it have you
know we'll be straightforward about it
I've seen some breakdowns of it but I
have not actually braved yeah I feel
like I don't care that it's gonna get
rid of it I don't care
watch it I've seen all of his pitch
meanings for the movies I've seen but
okay someone like Andrew Hayes at the
top reward tier request this video it's
not me because Angry Birds 2 is getting
surprisingly amazing reviews I know we
can the time of emoji movie Angry Birds
around the same time and then some of
the Angry Birds - he's got this
incredible rebound to happen at some day
tracking best Madhuri mentation / ah you
said you had a movie you wanted to pitch
to me yeah you're gonna like this one so
what's something that's a part of every
young person's life these days I don't
know Oh poop yes but also the use of
Modi's oh you see where I'm going with
this
no an emoji movie oh that's good because
they're super popular very popular so
what's the story
the what the story like what's the movie
about oh yeah
yeah I know I've got a bit of that in
here great yeah so the man emoji doesn't
want to be a Mamo G anymore honestly it
doesn't matter so much no no honestly I
think people are gonna be so pumped
about seeing emojis they're not gonna
care about story or character
development or substance or anything
like that that's a good point yeah so
basically we just have all the emojis
living in a city called techstop Alice
that is clever right because it's like I
took the word metropolis and I change
the beginning to text well the other
jokes in the movie or as funny as that I
think we're in business they are they're
all at that exact same level of humor
you have other examples
yeah there's the MoMA
there's monkey emojis with briefcases
and they're like we have business to
attend to
right and the memo geez like what kind
of business
haha and so one of the monkey says
monkey business oh my god that is gold
because they're monkeys they are I mean
I don't want to toot my own horn but
this is incredible it did great the
other people talk in the movie I mean I
don't really know how young people talk
these days oh I do and there's a ton of
that in here like sleigh NBD
hashtag blessed good that sounds like
we're in touch with the youth word now
what are some of the other character
apples he has parents yeah they're also
meds
so if emojis can have children that
means that they can the implication is
that emojis have intercourse and
reproduce yeah fascinating yeah it
really makes you picture it doesn't it
yeah it really does it's so many other
important characters yes there is a poop
emoji so like an animated piece of feces
yeah I think it'd be fun for the movie
to have a character that's an actual
talking piece of [ __ ] and what's his
role in the movie he's gonna make four
or five poop related puns all pretty
important and then also and what's he
like what was the thing words to mind
when you think of a high five um he's
British and has an eating disorder right
of course eat so much candy he vomits
several times just like a high five
would and actually that gives me an idea
with that maybe I can strike a deal with
the creators of candy crush and have the
characters go in their app I love it
that's gonna bring in a ton of money do
you think people will be bothered by the
product placement no people love product
placement oh that's great cuz I have
literally nothing planned for the second
act of the film oh so they can just go
from product placement into product
placement absolutely as many as you can
get I can get a lot perfect so let's
talk about casting for the main
character sure did you have anyone in
mind for me well I mean I have a dream
actor that I'd like to that it's a
little nuts I don't know if it's doable
just shoot TJ Miller oh it must be
impossible to get him though right
actually super easy
[Music]
the emoji movie done Wow
and this is really gonna blow your mind
what I think we might be able to get Sir
Patrick Stewart in this what how well
it's a kids movie he's a sweet old man
such a sweet man I think if we just
explained to him that this is what the
kids are into he'll do it out of the
kindness of his heart you would do it
for the kids
I honestly think he would if he thought
it could bring those enjoy what a great
man truly a saint
what emoji should he play I don't know
maybe the piece of [ __ ] it's very well
time hey guys Ryan here hope you enjoyed
that pitch meeting let me know in the
comment section what other move Olivia
Ryan pitch meetings for and keep an eye
on the community tab because we're gonna
have some polls in there where you can
vote on what we do next and if you're
new to screen before I Freeman yet
thanks for letting us did somebody we
know talk to this guy
Tyrone magnet Tyrone mm-hmm show that
photo hey Tyrone looks different he
looks very different yeah it's part of
his secondary channel get javi get javi
and jump on that time Magna sites so
yeah that was a great great video my
brother's because Tyrone's black yeah my
brother oh hey look at that
that's amount of white or Mexican
friends holding my black oh yeah oh you
specifically call me friend
yeah let's Jairo my brother brother axon
my brother farewell my brother mm-hmm
struggle nation my brother's even though
I only know one of the brothers oh damn
look at that
Roo I mean see you're lying that's what
I'm saying about your struggle nation
can I'm a liar you're a lying sack of
boji poops that was good John
it's funny about watching the old ones
as you really noticed a difference in
how he does them now
yeah they worked hand held yeah he has a
hand held the fact he had a person in
his apartment at the time when he used
to do it Adobe effect just the way the
delivery the pacing is different and I
noticed it and it's talked about a
little bit
in the interview I didn't watch the
whole thing this discussion is going to
be a paraphrasing of the interns yeah
that's all I'm gonna do is read from
there I can give you my own thoughts
yeah you do see it though first off the
green screen not a sharp no no yeah yeah
at this size it's been a while since
I've seen a pitch meeting out of right
the other thing is the energy of it is
different it feels a little less
heightened it feels a little bit more
like he's trying to go for a sense of
dry realistic delivery this is
incredible it did great with energy yeah
you know not like you're watching the
most realistic pitch meeting but there
seems to be more toned-down in this
energy to try to convey a little bit
more sincerity and delivery there's less
of that like shamelessly blissful
ignorance that comes out of the 2000
times there's less of the smile yeah
like that yeah you have another movie
for me yes sir I do like that's like the
energy and the delivery all the other
things it's so much more you know yeah
and now here it's a little bit more like
straight-faced especially especially the
producer character yeah who said the
catchphrase this time it must be
impossible to get him though right
actually super easy barely an
inconvenience really check this out
now that's why he's good cuz like I
think there's another one where they
actually call attention to it he's like
I usually say that but yeah usually it's
always the writer but in this one it was
him oh I never noticed that
Oh a Ryan George has like awesome
YouTube videos is his own channel you
guys gotta check out there's what I was
just showing as so many people the first
toxic fan ever oh the funniest things
I've ever seen so goddamn funny it's
like I'm laughing throughout and the
best joke is the last joke and I'll tell
you guys that preparing yourself for
that last and he'll still laugh and
you'll still find surprising yeah he's
sharp man and like he's great at making
Talking Heads compelling I gotta give it
to ya is like so much of his comedy is
sort of quick back and forth and really
in the choice of vocab and the rhythm of
the discussion that's happening he was
also on was Kevin Hart's YouTube
although hello lol network yeah network
use the stars in one of the series of it
whoa working actor writer Ryan George
and Casey Spivey who's done this channel
before apparently was like mentored by
him what she was participating that can
we go back in time so Ryan George we
rather we're like one time yeah yeah
totally that fits your previous metric
they grabbed earlier who you yeah I did
it yeah awesome man anyway about the
emoji movie yeah this sounds like
everything I've heard okay it sounds
yeah like everything I've heard and it
also sounds like a like I didn't even
love regular Ralf - but it sounds like a
very soulless version of wreck-it Ralph
- which I understand came out later it
sounds like it would be sluggish to sit
through yeah it's like there's a number
of movies that come out every year that
I hear is specially terrible and I'm
curious to watch them and the emoji
movie is not not is not one that sounds
fun to sit through even like I don't
know there's something that feels so
shameless at the root of it that the
movie it's not unfair because I haven't
seen it but nothing about the movie or
the ad campaign have suggested to me
that it was anything more right yeah I
feel like there was a yep here it is buy
it but still this was really funny how
it did it yeah I'm always a little bit
distracted when I go to the Past though
with him yeah it's like watching an
early Simpsons episode you're like oh
the animation is so much more clean and
I think the thing with pitch meetings
the emoji movies like perfect you're it
from everything I've heard about the
emoji movie it just sounds like the
product movie yeah I mean like
everything seems so calculated by
business heads that were controlling
everything about that female and to do a
pitch meeting for it I'm like that's why
it sounds like everything I've heard
before and in some ways I'm like this
seems like some of this could have been
the real conversation yeah down any
totally totally and those are always
like very special pitch meetings because
some of them have to lean more into the
comedic aspect but this one yeah is like
almost uncanny from every review I heard
of the emoji movie like they would even
come down to things that he commented on
in this review as being brush past
simple rules
simple concepts of how the world worked
so I wouldn't be at all surprised if it
was a completely product oriented pitch
you know because I don't think any
passionate writer was like always hope
Lego did it you know Lego has but Lego
has a lot of like childhood nostalgia
built in emojis have been around for a
couple of years ok fair you know what I
mean
yeah but they're so handy like I would
believe that Phil Lord and Chris Miller
grew up playing with Legos and then had
some inspirational nugget to work with
office so what you're saying is the
emoji movie came ten years too soon yeah
if this movie came out twenty years
later our who had been using emojis all
their young brilliant comedy all right
little self-aware humor anyway guys you
don't watch Angry Birds to this weekend
leave a comment below
well Andrew thanks for requesting this
my dude Andrew miss your face where you
gonna come back to California homie
listen he has his own YouTube channel
there's some movie reviews Andrew I just
want to say you trying to look like me
is that Regina Duke is and one of my
hairs comb back I mean I'm just saying
I'm looking at you right now and clearly
you got a different look going on
normally a short hair or a cat run and
now you got curly hair I didn't even
know yet curly hair is like best friends
now what best friends yep that's why
he's been hiding the Hat for so long
he's been he didn't want to show you the
curl you didn't think you and I could be
friends because my curls were better
that ID he's got a girl envy dude dude
no you got thank you guys stick together
me my brothers and curly guys I love you
Andrew I love especially now you have
curls I'm fine white I am white people